ready to debate this we have two
segments stay with us joining us now on
stage NRA spokesperson Dana lash who was
there last night Fox News contributor
Katie Pavlich Fox News correspondent
at-large Geraldo Rivera and Dan bond
genome
[Applause]
grab a seat grab a seat this is great
first I want to say I obviously didn't
watch because that they're on at the
same time but I watched later and number
one you did a phenomenal job under the
most difficult circumstances we got to
give you bring us behind the scenes you
were called a murderer
burn her what else yeah well let me set
the stage for you and and first off I
want to say that it's it's hard to be a
teenager it's hard being a grieving
teenager and it's hard being a grieving
teenager who's being exploited by a
media and made to grieve or asked to
grieve publicly on a national stage this
was an arena full of survivors victims
parents and other community members if
there were there were over 7,000 people
that were in this arena Sean and when we
entered you kind of entered like you
were floyd mayweather going into the
ring i mean literally like you came in
from part of the arena and you walked
through between all these people and you
got up on stage it was pretty chaotic it
started even before i got up on stage to
talk and i the whole reason why I showed
up there is because the NRA is made of
over five million members who are also
parents I'm one you're one of them and
you're a parent and we didn't do
anything wrong right we weren't the ones
I mean why is it that we're held
responsible when here just as you
mentioned just today we learned that the
Sheriff's Office here you had a deputy
who waited up words a for minutes before
they went in and Sean we also found out
it was reported this morning that the
parents have reported this murderer to
police before there's a report out there
the records have been have been
discussed in media where he they said
they told police he has threatened
people with a gun before he has held a
gun to other's heads now I'm not a
member of the FBI I'm not a member of
law enforcement I love what they do I
appreciate what they do you're not
biting this because you'd be oh hey you
know you do I've been I've been I've
been a second atomic supporter and in
every shot by the time that was a shot
keep shot by the sheriff because he's
trying to come as a liberal point of
view that's fine but what he did was
wrong it was wrong and he has questions
to answer all right let me ask you once
the question is I got it we have a big
we have you for two segments which is
great what other names were you called
while you were on that stage I was
called a see-you-next-tuesday
they they said burn her murderer I heard
a lot of murders and then they tried to
they Cersei Lannister chanted me shame
as I walked out and I did not I've
looked at every single person they want
a Jerry Springer last night yeah and and
that's what I mean honestly we have poor
Aldo but that's when CNN should have let
their cameras go because that was the
money shot that they wanted I'm sure
right and but they're people try to rush
the stage there was a woman who rushed
those scary and at one point Jake Tapper
said turned and looked at me and said do
you have an escort you need to get out
of here right now you have got to get a
cure right now and if I did not have a
3-person detail with me I would not have
gotten out of the arena
that is not an exactly in all fairness
Geraldo he's one of my best friends in
life we love him I disagree we disagree
on some things you believe in the Second
Amendment yeah I do I do you agree with
what I outlined for security measures I
absolutely agree with it but Dana said
it is hard being a teenager it is I'm
the father of five for them have passed
through the teenage years it is hard
being a teenager so why in the world
does the NRA resist raising the age for
the purchase of these deadly weapons
from 18 to 21 as the president now
advocates well this simple change this
simple choice I want the NRA to embrace
I want the NR idea here's a kid who has
visited 39 times by the cops
he's a kid they wouldn't let him carry a
knapsack into the school and yet this
ticket buy an ar-15 legally Haley's
right I will say this if there were so
many signs it is embarrassing they
didn't get this kid earlier you can't
buy a beer show but I will come back